the dark truth is that it's become very
hard to find anyone and certainly
anything more interesting than a
smartphone we love our phones and would
never want to give them up but we're all
probably also gently aware that these
delightful gadgets bear hidden cost to
say that we are addicted to our phones
is not merely to point out that we use
them a lot it signals a darker notion
that we use them to keep our own selves
at bay because of our phones we may find
ourselves incapable of sitting alone in
a room with our own thoughts floating
freely in our heads
daring to wander into the past and the
future allowing ourselves to feel pain
desire regret and excitement we are
addicted to our phones not because we
rely on them but to the extent that we
recruit them to a harmful project of
self avoidance they don't mean to hurt
us but we may and probably do use them
to injure ourselves addiction sounds
horrible but it's a hard name for a
normal inclination a habit of running
away from the joys and terrors of
self-knowledge
we can look up so much on our phones we
can if we're inclined check out the
population of Lima 8.7 3 million who won
the ladies final at Wimbledon in 1997
Martina Hingis the definition of
tautology saying the same thing twice
though in different ways or perhaps the
author of that fascinating quote what
you survive makes you stronger
Nietzsche yet this constant resource has
an unwitting unfortunate side-effect we
consult our phones rather than ourselves
it's not that we actually know so many
obscure facts it's that we already
possess in scattered unpolished forms
the raw material from which a huge
number of the very best insights and
ideas could be formed if
we gave them enough time and attention
almost since the beginning of time we
have prized the opportunity to get away
from reminders of humanity and to
immerse ourselves in nature we've wanted
to gaze on a grey indifference of the
ocean or the bright incalculable
immensity of the starry sky but our
phones are the enemies of such
experiences they keep intruding are
small selves into the picture we might
be on the edge of the Grand Canyon
they are beeping in our back pockets we
may be gazing at the southern slopes of
the Matterhorn they are receiving
updates for a food delivery app back
home they ask us never to forget our ego
and the endless things that al us
without meaning to they strip away the
help that the grandeur of nature can
offer us we constantly use our phones to
keep track of our appointments but we
are if we think about it quite
constrained around the things to which
we choose to be alerted
there's the automated reminder of the
session with a dentist the alert to jog
our memories that it's our parents
anniversary or the text message to let
us know which you to play tennis match
on Sunday afternoon but there are other
very different appointments we need to
keep in mind we need reminders to keep
appointments with ourselves we need to
spend time with our own worries to
understand them rather than just suffer
the anxiety they create the grandest and
much the worst is our final appointment
with death we don't know how many days
we have left to countdown but what we
need reminding of is not the day and the
hour but the fact ideally we'd get a
message every morning memento home oak
we are pull this s a tin Pulver M River
Terrace remember you are made of dust
and will be dust again our phones seem
amazingly sophisticated small miracles
of compressed practical science working
hand in hand with advanced capitalism we
think so highly of them because we
compare them to the past rather than to
the possibilities of the future they are
so much more advanced than any device we
possessed twenty or forty years ago yet
our phones are almost unbearably
primitive in comparison with what idea
the long future will bring we are still
so far from inventing the technology we
really require for us to flourish
capitalism has delivered only on the
simplest of our needs we can summon up
the street map of Lille but not a
diagram of what our partner is really
thinking and feeling the phone will help
us follow 15 news outlets but not help
us to know when we've spent more than
enough time doing so it emphatically
refuses to distinguish between the most
profound needs of our soul and a passing
fancy in the Utopia of phones will be
wiser than we are they will be kind and
not merely subservient they will know
how to address away from a stupid
decision and how to summon up our better
natures we deserve pity for having been
born in such primitive times we publish
new thought-provoking films every week
be sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now